[Music]
when i first started climbing i
i started going to all types of climbing
events
and
i noticed i was the only person of color
i went home and i was online and i
searched do black people rock climb
because i was really curious and my goal
was to try and find where all the black
climbers
i found this forms it said black people
don't climb and
i wanted to prove them wrong
you know growing up going to the woods
going outdoors was something that black
people didn't do you know at least
that's what i was told
in new york city you didn't really have
too many options for for sports it was
either basketball
football or baseball if you're close
enough to a park i wanted to bring a
fourth option to my community and that's
rock climbing
i co-founded brothers of climbing an
organization formed to tackle the lack
of diversity in rock climbing and to
help promote and encourage people of
color and underrepresented groups to get
in the outdoors
it's for men women anyone
if you feel underrepresented in climbing
you belong with us
when the group formed there were only
three of us and now there's dozens of us
and it's a great feeling
in new york city we host a monthly
meetup across the country we want to
host a festival and just other events in
other cities
[Music]
there are many reasons why there's a
lack of representation
in the sport of rock climbing
one reason is there's not too many
mentors within
our community teaching and spreading the
knowledge
you know when i grew up i never had that
also the industry doesn't do a great job
showing the diversity that is in the
sport
you can open up a catalog and you won't
find a person of color in it you know
the minute you get out there and you
start doing it and you realize how easy
it is
something clicks and and then you say i
can do this i can do this i'm doing it
i'm doing it and
i want other people to realize that
you